if he plays e4
maybe i will maybe i will try a stafford
[Music]
because i'm tilted i've lost two
nothing left to lose in life let's let's
go
wow it's ten thousand bits from the
admiral i'm sorry eric
i'm sorry i couldn't deliver oh thanks
so much
i really appreciate that but ten
thousand bits
really appreciate that okay let's let's
play stafford
motivation
i'm trying i'm trying
so he's walked into like one of the more
common lines
there's a few moves here for white
oh hi everyone or hello everyone
hello everyone i have to embody the
agent mata
thanks for that t kong i'm hari krishnan
and admiral thanks again so okay it's
nice to see he's a bit perplexed
and this this is one of the reasons why
the stafford gambit is such a good
opening for blitz
even against gm's because you just got a
time advantage
uh pretty early on if they're if they're
not prepared
um now of course like i'm risking just
getting a much worse position
if he plays accurately but i think it's
worth the risk
so i have a whole video on this um
which is on youtube actually i'd
probably have a good handful of videos
now
but there's one video which kind of goes
through all the traps
and people can use the stafford command
they want to
check that out so he plays h3
h3 is actually not a good move
uh because of this
yeah this is already like really really
bad for whites
it's funny after queen d4 the best move
is rook f1
this is a line the even stockfish it
won't realize how good it is for black
at first
like you have to let it running for a
little bit
um but i think
like if you're running if you leave it
running for long enough it will say
eventually minus two for black which is
already a winning advantage
uh the whole point i'm attacking f2
um and in the lines that white takes
the attack is so deadly with the half
open h file
um then there's an attempt queen e1 but
then that runs into queen e5
and it's actually like it's close to
force mate
so i'm slightly disappointed like i'm
not trapping him in like a more
important game like a title tuesday or
like an over the board
like blitz tournament but it's still
nice to get this against a gm
if i'm not mistaken hikaru fell into the
same line like recently
but he still won his white and he played
this move yeah this is the best move
um
it still takes a little bit of work
um but okay the attack is uh is raging
i guess bishop yeah bishop e3 is coming
i better not lose this i have to stay
focused i know it's good for black
i might as well take
and then there's some queen e5 move
yeah g3 but g3 i can play this and oh
there's still bishop e3
if i play queen d6 there's uh there's
king h2
interesting
okay i have time fidel is very low
on time
so queen e5 there's bishop f4 it's not
so simple actually
so h2 king h1 is forest bishop h3
i could play queen f6
and then idea of king h2 maybe take on
f2
it's interesting
[Music]
it's risky though
there's a question like how how much
risk i want to take also just checking
queen d6
that might be the most solid
yeah so now there's no more bishop e3
there's bishop f4 but i can swing the
queen over and go for
i think you can go for bishop g4
stack upon
oh actually i'm still threatening this
to win f2 or win the exchange
let's defend defending both things
so i want to play bishop h3 and castle
and then pressure d4
[Music]
it's kind of a scary move
start with queen h5 there's some idea of
this and then this
doesn't quite work though
[Music]
i also have g5 here maybe
let's do it running low on time
he's fighting well
this move is really cool i don't know if
it works though
running this
that's a cool mate stacking the rook
leaving the queen hanging but
uh okay we'll have to talk about this
opening afterwards
so anyway the the line you play i mean i
don't know i didn't like bishop
maybe i can play h3 actually so
yeah uh in this position h3 is a bit
more solid move
that's what i now and i'm thinking why
not h3 and then now you don't have uh
well you do have so it's funny if you
played h3 i was probably gonna play h5
still waiting for bishop e2
of course you can play d3 here you're
fine but uh
because screen d4 i can get bishop with
three should
of course that's what i should have done
so it's crazy here because h3 is like so
natural and then
it's already really really bad for white
after queen d4
and the best move here is rook f1 i
think i said it on i said on the stream
i was like okay i'm gonna play rook f1
but then i'm like no you know i have a
bad feeling about castling
i don't like that castling it looks
weird and the first thing i do of course
is
freaking castle and it's like knight g4
resign are you sir and well not so
resigned but
of course you you fight what is this
okay
i found what is this siri was listening
for and of course i spent like a minute
and a half on this position right yeah
and that's why i love this opening like
a lot of these lines you get a big time
advantage if the opponent's not familiar
yep so there's a cool line i don't know
if you you like calculate it and then go
for it
but if you do take the knight of course
it looks really risky
but takes and then g3 there's only one
way for black to get a winning position
here
actually i didn't go that far but i'm
because i use king g2
yeah okay feel free to take your time we
need five you're gonna play king g2
that's not gonna work
rook h3 i'm also gonna play king g2
and that doesn't look like working but
maybe because now you can just play like
bishop v6 or something
and just play for the h4 h file
interesting
[Music]
queen if queen f6 and that's on the
queen e5
can you two oh my god
you got i got a i got a rook h2 check
and in what in what variation
oh that's too much that's too much no i
was thinking about queen e5
king g2 it's almost working but it
doesn't quite work
no you got king ji one and escape there
right that's not gonna work
i guess rook h3 is good enough
uh but then just king g2 rook h1 like
on the surface it looks like white's
going to defend
but there's a very concrete way
okay what else can you do here queen d6
doesn't work queen
and yeah i would encourage chat to try
and find it too i i think there's some
people who know it
one minute one minute of course one
minute and i killed this how to do
this one takes
[Music]
yeah you guys should try it out too by
the way
there's definitely some people who are
watching who know it because i i did a
whole like youtube video covering this
slime
i mean some someone's saying queen takes
f2 but of course that doesn't work
we take swing
that doesn't mean that cannot do b that
cannot be
if i play bishop e6 to try to long
castle
but it doesn't really work queen f queen
e5 uh king g2
yeah you can't play slowly here wing
somewhere bishop takes f2
wait what what were you saying i'm just
saying some queenie fighting you two
maybe bishop takes f2
king takes f2 i got rook h2 check is
made if you go up
i'm going to draw arrows just for people
watching because you're saying this
this this boom if king takes you do this
this might be it there you go queen h5
yeah so the whole the whole point is
yeah of course you're threatening mates
it's incredible line yeah
that's amazing but it looks like black
white black white is escaping after all
because queenis fights only it's not
even threatening mate
yeah no on the surface it looks
completely fine um and
like most players will play this if they
get to this position and
bishop takes off two is completely
winning for black
wow and that way group takes off took we
need five that would play rook f4 maybe
to try to get out uh yeah the the
problem is i've had this position i
think once on the chest
and then now you just do that so queen
h2 and queen xg3 is winning
oh my god yeah no no yeah no one
i mean you wouldn't well if someone
tells you there's something you probably
find it but it's
in but it is hard to yeah figure it out
on your own and i
i remember like discovering this maybe
about a year ago just with the engine
and uh then subsequently got it in games
have you gotten any title players on
this uh
so yeah so there's been a handful um
i got kustinook in this castino
alexandria costa yeah but but she what
happened she
uh she played bishop takes g4 and she
beat me
it was like some title tuesday or arena
kings oh so you didn't get her on h take
g4 i'm talking about this line
oh and this line uh yeah i found at
least one game in the masters database
that i had
um so when you say the master database
is that the database
or sorry it's the leachat database
if you click the opening book icon
it usually defaults to the masters
database oh okay okay there on there
but then you can toggle if you click the
settings icon
nice uh you can toggle between the two
send me the link
if you don't mind send me a link of that
website that you say that you can oh
yeah it's just opening tree.com
opentree.com i'll type it in the wechat
chat
that's really cool that's really cool
check it out well i'm obviously not up
today
with a lot of things yeah i mean this is
my livelihood it's just playing
tricky openings and watching people
suffer
the latest gambits yeah and like the fun
line here is after
it's more after king takes you play rook
h2 king e3 you take on g3
the king is dragged into the center and
you're down two pieces but you just
calmly develop in castle queen sign
something long castle oh my god
that's so great that's on blue
wow that will be brilliant surprise for
sure
oh yeah yeah i've like i think i had
this once on chess.com
but never never only chess and on
again someone like high-rated player or
just like like just an anyone because
being someone with uh you know like
maybe like a 2 500 or something on
chess.com would be to be tough i mean
would be nice
right getting someone on it actually so
uh
hikaru walked into this at least walked
into this night g4 line
um in one of like his speed run things
against the gm
well that makes you feel better thank
you yeah but he played bishop takes g4
and ended up winning
as white which is what i did i i mean i
feel like at some point i kind of had
something here
yeah it's like it's not so easy i'm
realizing um
i shouldn't take on h3 like black still
has to play precisely here
maybe you can play queen f6 or something
starfish is recommending queen d6 which
is kind of interesting
i thought about queen d6 it came to my
mind for a second but like leaving the
tension
and i can already take and you could
then the threat is to take and you can't
play g3
because i take that's the big one so i
probably have to go e5 looks natural but
then queen g6
wow that's so nice and now d4 but then
you take the one on h3
and now your bishop is way better than
white bishop
right way better so maybe there's some
line like d4
takes g3 and with the queen on g6 i'm i
have bishop
g4 here
yes yeah it's pretty big oh there's a
funny line here and if uh
if queen d3 i check and oh my
there's issues with takes takes
because yeah king's youtube bishop h3
yeah it doesn't work wow
that was just so i i love teaching these
openings
like there's so many traps it'll inspire
players to uh this is amazing especially
quickly as players i mean you you want
to get into this crazy stuff
because it really develops your
imagination so exactly
really good really good to learn all
this also it's good to learn to play
down up down material
when you're starting because you're not
going to be playing as much
down material when you get higher levels
people drop pawns
or nights or stuff yeah i know it
teaches you how to be aggressive and
like find
find initiative and attack and that's a
different style of playing